[Music]
all right so you guys know andrew tate's
off of uh
facebook instagram you mean the top g
the top g i just saw this morning he was
uh he's banned off of grinder now he was
on grinder what
so i made a post did they need to do
that
he's probably killing on grindr dude i
wonder i haven't seen him
so i he created like an hour and a half
long video called my final message
we're just gonna i'm sure none of you
guys have seen it right now okay good
good good farewell
on my feed you know does it end with a
gun in his mouth
[Laughter]
not that i condone that
so um we're going to go ahead and react
to some specific clips of it which is
sorry andrew tate this is what he hates
that people clip his [ __ ] and then he
gets thrown out of context
but he's like watch the whole thing i
don't got an hour 30 to [ __ ] watch
we're not the first [ __ ] couple i
haven't even watched a full podcast with
them so if you take my woman hating out
of context it's pretty bad
and he does address that and he
addresses a lot of stuff so here's some
choice cuts oh he's got box water in the
back
[Laughter]
looks like he's recording from like a
prison be careful if you guys are
impressionable youths this could be a
danger to you all right i might go home
and people in my position of fame have
had women come forward and say he raped
me i'm the most famous man on the planet
there's not a single female whose face
you can name or whose face you can
picture that's come forward and said
i've raped her not a single female has
come forward saying i've hurt her
not one there's a video from 10 years
ago that showed me
in a sexual act with one of my
ex-girlfriends
[ __ ] i didn't say the word list did i
say listen
hello everyone um i just wanted to say
something about the video that's been
released recently about me and my
ex-boyfriend entertained andrew is my
still great friend what you guys saw on
the video it's just what we used to do
role play
he's a great guy he will never hurt
anyone
unless he's fighting
right after that's like hashtag ad
so that's that first one so he addressed
that what do you guys think
i like it better than the will smith
apology
i was actually thinking the same thing
it seems so far so good okay
so the context behind that was that was
going around as proof as he's beating
women so that clip that clip of him
doing that was one of the like for the
people that hate him that was one of
their strongest pieces of evidence and
they looked at it like it was some kind
of like leaked footage that exposed him
but what were they it was a leaked sex
tape like did they end up [ __ ]
afterwards i don't know but but they
said that they were both
yeah so it was like it was like uh what
do you call it like the the dominatrix
kind of foreplay kind of thing okay
that's your jam dominatrix no woman has
come forward
saying i raped her
this is proof that i have never raped
anybody
none have lived to tell the tale
come on man
i know it's pretty that's why all right
sure that's a feather just cap dude
yeah so that's that one well i mean that
is pretty bold because that's like if a
girl was raped actually you [ __ ]
yeah right she could call him out
yeah she could but that hasn't happened
okay how women are unique and special
and they can do things that men can't do
and still these clips are taken out of
context
let me give you an example i absolutely
not really i love the transition i have
nothing against women i believe women
are the most precious things on the
planet they create life they should be
protected they should provide it for i
would never let a woman pay for a bill i
would never let a woman if someone
touched any of my woman i would stand up
against 10 men by myself and risk my
life to protect her
beautiful creatures i just don't think
that they're as emotionally calm as men
in stressful situations i don't think
they can fight like a man can and for
the same reason i would never drop my
children in an all-male nursery i think
that's strange and weird that is weird
[Laughter]
michael jackson's
such a good father
so somebody
has made a tick tock where it says men
do certain things and it shows videos of
me driving around cars spending money
and women do certain things it shows
women cleaning
women do certain things some men do
certain things
somebody off their own back somebody
else has made that video and now i look
like i'm saying women should only clean
and men should only run around with cars
yeah where did they get that from i want
to shoot stock footage bro
it looked like some like norwegian video
right yeah
we cleaned the house
what the [ __ ] is that it's funny because
i've even seen that and i didn't know
that he didn't make that
so people thought that he made that well
yeah because i think everything that's
out there like with his face and [ __ ] on
it it's like his own [ __ ] material
this is why i just thought he was an
extreme character i didn't think that
any of this [ __ ] was real oh no it's
real that's why it just [ __ ] blew my
mind cause i'm like when i see [ __ ] like
that i'm like dude this is so bizarre it
has to be fake but what has he said that
is i mean beyond the stuff we've seen
like that is actually bad top top three
things that have gone around that people
are most at least what i hear they're
upset about is his thing saying um
women who are raped should bear part of
the responsibility i mean that's
preposterous
about that alone it's like all right
did you hear that out of context yeah
if they were raped by me
that's what he said right
if anyone's been a victim of a crime
should they bear any part of the
responsibility at all well i guess in it
depends on what the crime is maybe i
guess in context
the crime is right
there's no context you don't need
context for it and then it's a [ __ ]
crime that you're a victim too he called
it rape not consensual sex i know his
whole thing about also his thing about
saying that women are should be the
property of mad but she here's the thing
he sees that as like a compliment to the
woman because it's like hey i'm taking
you in and i'll do everything for you
but i own you but i own you yet you are
my dog
now go sniff this [ __ ]
i'll go find somebody
okay so yeah so yeah that is also strike
two okay
we're doing good but the third strike
yeah he's got some real strong victorian
values is what i'm saying
yeah he does have some pretty uh you
know he's a man of 1823. the guy makes
interesting content though to say the
least right if there's one thing we can
credit him with it's like he knows how
to captivate a [ __ ] audience yeah
hitler gave great speeches that's what
i'm saying the whole world is just like
wow
i've never even pictured an all-male
nursery
i was like yeah that would be weird
actually it's a kid's creator dude all
male nursery is pretty [ __ ] funny
he's like i'm not dropping my kid off at
an all-male nursery oh that's a weird
picture
so here he is talking about um his band
from instagram instagram and meta have a
responsibility to show that they are
listening to the public they want to
show that they are listening
i have some good people on the case and
dialogue with instagram i would like to
open and we'll proceed as god sees there
if god believes that i
can you imagine god taking time off to
go does andrew tate deserve an instagram
page that's his number one priority
right now that's [ __ ] ridiculous my
pictures were just lifestyle
car house boat i never broke any rules
on instagram i never had any strikes
never done
so the only
infringements you would find on
instagram is in my comment section where
thousands of people who were sent by
random youtubers who don't like me
would come
threaten to kill me
make lock my dead father threatened to
kill my brother threatened to kill my
family threatened to find me
these were the only rule infringements
on instagram things written against me
by other youtubers telling them to go
and do it while all i wrote is poetry
and
and
on repeat you should be banned
for writing poetry
if you're going to defend me do it
respectfully
we really just banned that dude off of
poetry yeah you should
i think you should no no anyone that's
doing poetry should be just absolutely
jailed
that's some wax cars house boats
poetry
that's a haiku
i'm pretty sure no he said he's only
posting pictures if there's good poetry
it was probably bad poetry
can we find some poetry did he really
just post like cars and
like lifestyle [ __ ] on his own instagram
he never said anything about girls or
anything i think on his own instagram
that i mean all the stuff that you're
seeing that's making it out there it's
all tick-tock
the stuff yeah or like his own lives and
[ __ ] like that but on his instagram yeah
that's that kind of did it is weird yeah
he didn't really
do that
but that's i mean look not to be serious
but instagram is a
private it's a public company but it's
still private enterprise yeah they can
do what the [ __ ] they want yeah that's
what happens andrew there are
consequences to your actions
and sometimes there's consequences to no
actions yeah you know which is cool
because he's not saying that like they
sh he's just saying that he's it's
unfortunate they did that and he wishes
they didn't he bears some of the
responsibility but only god had been
wearing that
yeah
don't take as a rare male role model
there's better ones
where are they
there are no other male role models
because to inspire the youth of men you
need to be aspirational they have to
look at you and want to be like
and there's no other male role models
that have had the tenacity or the
aggressiveness to have such a fantastic
life as i have
that they're gonna listen to him
they listen to me because of my
authority and my authority comes from my
life experiences if my mentality is so
wrong how have i managed to amass
enormous slow have i managed to amass
huge social status how i managed to
physically dominate the planet do
but me being alive on the internet will
allow me to lead men in a very positive
direction
banning me and deleting me leaves a
black hole where they say they'll be
another masculine leader but the men
don't listen the youth of today won't
listen to anybody else that's the reason
i'm the most famous man on the planet
because none of these other people have
the authority to affect them like i do
my house was
what do you think of that i was low-key
like almost following him on the
previous statement and he got he got too
wild yeah and then that one is just so
true
[Laughter]
where are they anthony
zakawa those are
the new masculine leaders of today i
mean it is true there's not another guy
quite like him
right now i think jackson wang dude i
think jack
there's someone we can [ __ ] look at
okay he's the chinese rock no other dude
got any nominations yeah who do you
think should be i think guys that are
good role models don't [ __ ]
self-proclaim that [ __ ] cause they're
too busy being a [ __ ] dope-ass human
being well you guys need to start
proclaiming my drop
boom jojo but also
here okay so here's the thing about
progressing as a human being right so
like everyone's attracted by the primal
thing so
when they see andrew tate they see
wealth on the surface they see a guy
that has a [ __ ] car
that's really nice they have the jet
life all that they have the girls right
and then they see a guy that can also
[ __ ] fight all these things are
pretty [ __ ] it's like pretty like oh i
wish i could have that sure if you're if
you're a guy in high school hands down
or even a guy that's in his [ __ ] 40s
like that is if you've never tasted that
before that is something that's like on
the surface it's like i [ __ ] want
that just like
seeing it's it's that glimmery thing
that draws you in or like even on a on a
more basic level like let's say you see
a fit human being and you're like i want
to be as fit as that right so that that
begins the journey but everyone knows
that when you start it off and then you
get in what attracted you in the first
place always morphs into something else
because you know that those things are
very temporary so i think it's like a
good i don't know what his lesson is we
gotta sign up for his multi-market
good it's really good
and then you gotta get other people
saying i'll give you guys my login a lot
of people respond to that because it
just it appeals to that primal desire of
like every man wants to be [ __ ] dan
bilzerian and be able to choose whatever
the [ __ ] whoever they want to [ __ ]
it's like immediately they get like
every guy has that fantasy that's why
[ __ ] porn is so so like popular right
people will deny and be like no i want a
safe strong good marriage but it's like
they want to [ __ ] you jack off at all
that's the double standard that's where
it lies i better stop jacking off man
see this is the man leader we all need
i'm telling you see the void already
happened and it got filled already thank
you for filling the void the black hole
is gone we appreciate it and it's the
form of judging sakawa and berkeley and
i won't even charge this feels like that
dude remember that that show the game
yeah michael douglas no
that that was the the dude that was like
teaching how to like manipulate women oh
yeah like the pickup artist yeah
mystery yeah he looks like chris angel
feels like one step above that
he's he's evolved it yeah yeah right
well he's he's for like the incels bro
like the guys who like this guy are like
the inselly kind of
the dudes and i think they like that guy
the guy who loved the game this is the
next level of this the guy now he's not
like a creepy magician
he doesn't have a big-ass jamiroquai
it's called peacocking actually
it feels like if you watched as a as a a
a straight
successful person i watched this game
like this dude is nothing but a con
artist yeah that's what it feels like
when you watch like i can't see anyone
aspiring to be this guy but and someone
was just like this money power all this
[ __ ] something to chase what we need is
someone like you says it's like
life is meaningless uh don't chase
anything just hugely out of everybody
yeah you said that's what you need in
america you know
i almost feel like this is necessary for
a person's growth to
do it and realize why it's stupid yeah
so then they need to go through the
phase and hopefully they don't burn too
many people or do anything illegal along
the way but it's almost like everyone
gets in a pyramid scam to see why it
[ __ ] sucks to do like us in the
church honestly exactly like it's a part
of just real life
why am i here
yeah welcome
to the church
[Music]
[Music]
you